- So, here's the thing,
now, I'm a hustler, okay?
So I went to New York, no
money. I had one friend there.
I was sleeping on her
couch, and I would take jobs
at temp agencies to
sort of make ends meet,
to feed myself, right?
So, literally, on the corner
of 125th Street and Broadway,
there was a phone booth.
This is how long ago that was,
you know.
- Yep, phone booth.
- Phone booth.
- It wasn't a cell phone.
Okay, it was a phone booth.
And I would call into the temp
agency every single morning.
I would start calling them at 7:30,
call 'em every 15 minutes
until I got a job.
And like, it took like
six weeks (chuckles)
for me every single day
calling and then getting a job.
Finally, it was like the golden day
when I got a job to be the receptionist
at Spike's advertising agency.
- Oh, wow!
- And so I get there,
and I'm only supposed
to answer the phones.
Now, I see he's carrying
around something under his arm,
coming back and forth in the office.
It happened to be the
script for "Bamboozled,"
and I asked him if I could read it,
being an African-American studies,
you know, literature person.
(Kelly laughing)
I thought I could perhaps
give him some tips.
(woman laughing)
- You know what I mean?
- I love it!
Bold, though.
- Yeah, and naive. (chuckles)
- No!
- But was perfect.
Because it's like,
I think today I probably
would've hesitated, right?
I would've been like, "Oh, Spike,
like how can you even give
him any kind of tips at all?"
But at the time, I was like,
"Oh yes, I'm gonna do him a favor."
(Kelly claps)
(audience laughs)
You know what I mean?
- Totally.
- I took the script, I marked it up,
give it back to him.
(Kelly laughing)
He looked at me like I
had lost my whole mind,
(all laughing)
and, no,
but he looked at it and said,
"Okay, like, actually you
make some good points.
You should stay here for a while.
- Oh gosh.
- That's my gosh that I got.